. Let's get right into hatred, hate mail,
no time to waste hatred mail. Of course, when
a professional voiceover artist does interpretive
readings of the hate mail that I get. Quick
reminder about Patriot mail
[inaudible]
it's like a mandatory transvaginal ultrasound
for your mind. Patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pacman because America and
because freedom
and of course, uh, the typical sorts of critiques
we've heard before from hatred mail this week.
Let's take a listen
David pack man. Get a life. You're a loser.
David Pacman and as loser followers pretend
to be nuanced and individual thinkers, Trump
is just the biggest leader ever. And the left
Democrat losers are just poor losers. Geo
engineering, including chem trails, AKA solar
remediation is the cause of climate change.
David Pakman is a lying scumbag loser. You
know this actually, uh, I, I wouldn't say
it gets to me, but it does make me question
once again, why do I need to lie on the program?
I have no boss who might fire me if I say
the truth. The only people who hold me accountable
are the viewers. And uh, there is no advantage
to lying. There is just no incentive to do
it. And of course I can get things wrong and
people can disagree with my conclusions, but
this idea that I come on the program and deliberately
lie, I don't even understand what there is
potentially to gain from that, but yet it
is a common trope of Patriot mail. Remember
that you can use the coupon code hatred at
40 to sign up for membership on our website
at a 40% discount. You save 40% the hatred.
It's cry and independent media is strengthened.
It's the trifecta. That coupon code is spelled
H a T R I O T for zero. You can use it on
any membership@joinpacman.com to save 40%
but you do get 100% of the member benefits.
Check it out.